- We're throwing a pasta party!
I would just call it yay.
Oh God. I could eat baked ziti every day.
- Girl, you got the power.
Have either one of you been glamboozled?
Or have you been the glamboozler?
- People are getting busy
and being real loud about it.
Is there someone here who
doesn't like Robert Pattinson?
I am not George Costanza
who wants to eat a Turkey sandwich
and do it, if you know what I mean.
(Drew laughing)
Oh God, no.
Oh my God.
Gosh darn you.
Oh!
- Bring it on.
- Oh no!
Oh no, no.
No!
(Drew yelling)
- Oh my God, shut up!
- Hi baby!
(Drew slurping)
(Drew hissing)
- [Ross] Yeah.
- I'm eating!
Feel that, Rossy.
- Look it, look it, let me see.
Hey!
- Wow, she got guns.
- Wow.
(all laughing)